(bright music)
Oh, VFFs,
you look so fantastic!
Speaking of looking fantastic, our next guest,
she used to walk runways all around the world.
And like us now, she's cooped up at home
juggling work and three kids
with some very creative thinking.
Oh yeah, this photo went totally viral,
(crew laughs)
and why not?
Come on, it's so fun. Great sense of humor.
Everyone, it's Molly Sims.
(crew cheers)
Hi, how are you?
Wow, Molly,
you look gorgeous!
Oh, thank you.
I'm so glad I could join you guys today.
I also noticed that you're rocking a beautiful pale color
in the waterline of your eyes,
which is making them look oh so sparkly.
Oh so sparkly, just a little bit.
I love beauty and makeup and all things that,
and all things that are pretty.
Let me just start by saying,
look, there are plenty of websites out there.
I've poured through so many of them.
Yours really is so much of a cut above.
It is so elevated.
Thank you.
It's such an amazing,
wonderfully like, navigational site,
and all those things count.
No, but really,
yeah, we really wanted to have a place
where women could go and, you know,
be a mom, be a partner, be a girlfriend, be a wife.
But also, the products that she needs, it's all curated.
It's a one-stop shop.
I really do love it.
I mean, we have great gift guides that are curated.
We have real articles.
I lost my mom this year, and we talk a lot about grief.
Then we talk about girlfriends, and just really digging,
just digging a little bit deeper than before.
This year has been such a year of loss
and such a year of new experiences
and new coping mechanisms.
Yeah, I never thought, you know, I never thought that,
listen, she was definitely sick.
I just never thought that I would lose, you know,
my best friend, you know, during,
during a pandemic, you know?
(sniffles) But it's been hard, you know?
But it's also, it's been great
because I've had such a great community reach out to me,
and I've had great people to speak to.
And it's just, it's definitely, you know, a process.
And I think sometimes in our business
that we only show like, the filtered Instagram,
like perfect part.
And life's just not like that, you know what I mean?
Sadly, more people can relate
to your experience-
I know.
Of going through something so difficult
than they can the fabulousness.
And this year, I actually spent Thanksgiving alone,
and I hadn't done that since I was in my 20s.
And my kids were with their dad this year,
and they just kind of wanted to do their own thing.
But I, it was just such a different holiday,
and such a different year for everybody.
And I can't tell you how much that,
how appreciated your candor
and being able to share that with people.
It's gonna touch people so much,
because unfortunately, again, sadly,
there are so many people who have experienced-
I know.
So much loss this year.
And when they look at a beautiful, kind woman like you
and they see themselves and their experiences,
that's what makes your website so much more.
And I must say, Molly, that I really think
that you should write a book.
(Molly chuckles)
Because one of my favorite things about your website
is what a great writer you are.
You took a nighttime routine
and turned it into something
(Molly laughs)
that I was so transported to.
And it just had this honesty and this humor.
I literally, I was like, doing something in my closet.
I was probably either eating in my closet,
drinking in my closet, sleeping my closet
or hiding in my closet.
(all laugh)
But it's just, you know, you have those moments of like,
you're literally gonna have a nervous breakdown.
And then, the next time you're like,
"Oh my God, I'm gonna just,
"I'm just gonna laugh at like, the craziness of all of it."
But yes, I love being open.
I think sometimes we do, you know, cover up the things
that people kind of wanna see.
And you know, my kids sometimes literally look at me
and they're like, "You're, you're literally gonna,
"you're gonna really tape us to the ground?"
I'm like, "We're gonna have so much fun,
"and I'm gonna get something done for 15 minutes!"
(all laugh)
Everybody loved that post.
I know!
I saw it,
and I was like, "That is so cool. That is so clever."
Yeah, we're in real life.
You're in it, I'm in it, you know?
And it's like, okay, it's like,
"Am I ready for 2020 to be over?"
I have to say, I'm ready for 2020 to be over.
But it's, some good things have come out of it, as well.
I was making a joke to my daughter
and I actually put in, I have this like 2012,
a Honda Odyssey minivan.
(Molly laughs)
And I love it,
because it has like a big screen in the back.
I have a Chrysler Pacifica minivan actually.
Oh my gosh, I'm looking into it,
because I'm trying to find
a hybrid minivan.
Oh my God!
And it's like, the only one on the market.
I love my minivan.
I'm obsessed with my minivan.
It's awesome.
Also, I know this is gonna sound bad,
but I want my children as far away from me
in my car as possible.
(all laugh)
Like if I could, I'd drive a stretch limo
with the thing that went up.
So I put on "Groundhogs Day" for them,
and none other than Andie MacDowell do I see
on a news program the next morning?
And someone's like, "Ah 'Groundhogs Day,' isn't that crazy?"
And she said, "Yeah, but you know, that movie is actually
"about living the same day over and over
"so that you have a chance to reevaluate your life
"so you can do things differently."
And I was like,
"Whoa!"
You know,
(crew chuckles)
this year has definitely
taught us, like you said about "Groundhogs Day,"
it's like really, you know,
those days you do get to have over and over now.
And sometimes that's not all bad, you know?
Molly, will you come hang out with us right now
for the next segment?
(laughs) I would love to!
I really don't wanna say goodbye.
I love hanging out with you.
You have so much to offer the world,
and you have SoME Beauty and mollysims.com.
Will you come hang out with me, us?
I would love to!
(bright music)